elle a été incarcérée après avoir été
mise en examen pour meurtre viol avec de
torture et de barbarie
elle est incarcérée le 18 octobre et
compte tenu de la nature de son crime
j'ai envie de vous dire de ces crimes
même s'il n'y a qu'une victime parce
qu'il y a plusieurs crimes
elle est évidemment
surveillée c'est sans doute la détenue
la plus surveillée de France d'abord
parce qu'on ne veut pas qu'il lui arrive
quelque chose qui permettrait de la
soustraire du système judiciaire on ne
veut pas qu'elle se qu'elle mette un
terme assez jour qu'elle se suicide
parce que pour les mêmes raisons la
famille a besoin d'une réponse
judiciaire et donc d'un procès donc on
laisse surveille et malheur au directeur
de prison
s'il devait sortir téléphoner au garde
des sceaux donc parliez tout à l'heure
pour lui dire ben écoutez j'ai eu un
petit problème on a eu un défaut de
surveillance donc ils ont mis en place
des mesures
draconiennes elle est donc à l'isolement
dans une cellule de 9 mètres carrés
toute seule à Fresnes elle est
surveillée en quasi permanence il y a
même on a mis un cahier
dédié pour elle c'est que le directeur
de la prison a exigé que l'on que les
surveillants qui sont en contact avec
elle note au quotidien et j'ai envie de
vous dire presque heure par heure
toute chose qui pourrait être
inhabituelle
après dans sa cellule
vraiment ils font que ça oui un cahier
dédié pour Dabia changement d'humour
si elle a des réflexions désagréables à
l'égard des surveillante
si elle prend sert pas si elle prend pas
ses repas là on a noté par exemple qu'on
la surprise en train de chanter en train
de danser ça a été noté
donc ça c'est l'une dans sa cellule
alors détail quand même donc elle passe
le plus clair de son temps allongé
précise selon elle regarde beaucoup la
télévision elle s'intéressait beaucoup
aussi à son histoire à l'époque où enfin
on fait toujours d'ailleurs mais à une
époque où on en parlait sur toutes les
chaînes et quasiment en continu
elle regarde donc la télévision elle
refuse les douches elle refuse des
promenades en revanche elle pense il
repart d'accord et quand elle a un
parloir avocat ou une visite médicale
la prison est bloquée tous les
mouvements de la prison sont bloqués
pour éviter justement qu'elle ne croise
un
une autre détenue ou quelqu'un qui
pourrait éventuellement l'agresser donc
là elle refuse de sortir de sa cellule
donc elle sort elle sort jamais
elle a refusé ouais donc vous dites les
douches elle ne veut pas aller à la
douche elle ne veut pas aller à la
promenade enfin en tout cas mon avis ces
informations
alors on le voit incarcéré dans la
prison de Fresnes dans l'attente de son
procès elle est dans quartier donc ces
quartiers d'isolement ce que vous pouvez
préciser pour nos téléspectateurs
quartiers d'isolement c'est un quartier
on va demander à Cédric quartier
d'isolement c'est le quartier
d'isolement sur le quartier spécifique
de la détention qui qui qui qui prône
son nom d'isolement c'est un quartier où
les personnes de nuit sont placées et
isolés du reste de la population pénale
alors
aujourd'hui elle est donc à la prison de
ferme
est-ce que c'est une punition ou c'est
plutôt pour sa protection qu'elle soit
en isolement c'est plutôt pour sa
protection c'est les deux c'est les deux
il y a dans la détention il y a une
notion de punition et puis aussi une
question une notion de protection c'est
pas un détenu lambda elle a commis
l'effet que l'on connaît et elle peut
elle peut enfin à mon avis elle a une
espérance de de survie si on la lâche
dans la cour de promenade d'un quart
d'heure c'est ça vraiment c'est ça se
passe comment justement parce qu'il y a
Cédric Boyer qui était avec nous suivre
surveillant pénitentiaire parce que les
téléspectateurs qui nous regardent ils
se disent tous comment ça elle a une
durée de vie d'un quart d'heure si elle
sort en promenade tout le monde dit
voilà il y a des surveillants il y a des
à quoi ils servent voilà comment ça se
passe c'est vraiment à chaque fois on
lui dit ça je dis bon voilà c'est vrai
que j'ai énormément de de pote qui est
voilà qui sont qui sont placard ou qui
sont déjà sortis de prison et qui moi
raconté voilà nombreuses donc c'est vrai
que c'est un petit peu comment ça se
passe voilà mais c'est vrai que le grand
public ils se disent comment ça elle a
une durée de vie de 15 minutes est-ce
que vous pouvez nous expliquer Cédric
parce que les gens se disent ils font
les surveillants comment ils comment ils
laissent passer ça comment ça se passe
mais écoutez déjà je vais pas vous
régler plus que vous savez déjà suite à
son incarcération au lendemain toute la
France entière su qu'elle était placée à
l'isolement mais l'isolement
là c'est une inférieure ultra médiatique
mais les procédures d'isolement il
existe des des centaines en France
métropolitaine et sur les stations
d'outre-mer c'est au regard des faits
qui qui sont reprochés aux personnes
détenues et à la répercussion que ça
peut peut avoir en détention et le choc
que ça a causé aussi à l'opinion
publique qu'il y a ces musées qui sont
prononcés évidemment il en va de soi
pour garantir sa protection sa sécurité
mais aussi dans le cas de la prise en
charge dans un quartier spécifique autre
que la détention classique donc quand on
dit elle tient elle tiendrait pas un
quart d'heure en promenade ça veut dire
qu'il va il va se passer quoi mais peut
avoir des règlements de compte il peut
avoir au regard des faits qui lui sont
reprochés il peut avoir forcément des
répercussions évolution au niveau de la
peau
il faut savoir que un surveillant
aujourd'hui
une centaine de personnes d'étouffes
dans un étage ordinaire et quand le
détenu ils sont en promenade il faut
savoir que les surveillants ils sont pas
en train de ils sont pas en promenade
avec les détenus ils sont dans un poste
de surveillance pour se les détenus en
promenade ensuite en cas d'incident il
faut remonter l'information pour pouvoir
intervenir assez rapidement là la
détention d'isolement ça permet d'avoir
une promenade tout seul donc qui a aucun
risque d'agression de la part de notre
personne détenue et on profite tout le
mal d'ailleurs de l'isolement c'est vrai
que vous voyez pas tout le monde tout le
monde là voilà hallucine ce qu'ils
disent donc si elle va en promenade
c'est sûr elle va se faire passer à
tabac
bien sûr pensez qu'il peut voilà et elle
peut oui on l'a vu avec Colonna dans un
autre contexte ça va très vite et
surveillants pénitentiaire ils peuvent
rien faire là-dessus les surveillants
pénitentiaires ça va très vite si vous
avez une lame
au moment où on se croise dans le dans
la coursive claque le surveillant même
si elle dit mètres il a pas le temps de
réagir c'est un coup dans la gorge donc
pour éviter ça c'est la raison pour
laquelle on la met justement à
l'isolement de manière à prendre combien
de temps l'isolement c'est pas moi qui
décide seulement soit par le magistrat
ou la détention donc
en tout cas pour l'instant elle est
passée à les hommes mais avec la
question pourquoi est-ce pourquoi est-ce
qu'il risque autant enfin tous les gens
qui sont en prison pardon un peu de
choses près on fait les mêmes choses
mais n'importe quoi
arrêtez s'il vous plait tu peux pas dire
ça tu peux avoir tu peux prendre 20 ans
pour un braquage
peut prendre 20 ans de prison voilà mais
le braqueur ne supportera pas le viol
exactement
dans la même dans les voleurs on est
dans les dans les promenade comme vous
avez dit c'est pareil voilà donc il y a
rien et ça c'est en prison les pointeurs
les les meurtriers d'enfants ça on sait
que c'est voilà ça ça ça ça tient pas ce
qu'on dit c'est ça tient pas en
promenade 10 minutes
le débat les chéris le débat et surtout
la question c'est qu'il y a plein de
gens pourquoi aujourd'hui vous êtes la
Cédric et pourquoi vous êtes là Michel
il y a énormément de gens qui ont appris
les conditions des tensions de Dabla et
qui sont dit elle a ruiné donc la vie de
famille entière de la France entière
quand ça se drame et il y a plein de
gens j'ai vu plein de gens dire voilà
bah là elle est tranquillement en train
de regarder la télé donc ça c'est s'agit
aujourd'hui qui dérange les les
téléspectateurs et les twittos et les
les français ce qui choque
particulièrement c'est à la fois qu'elle
regarde la télé et son comportement elle
danse elle chante apparemment Cédric va
nous le confirmer elle aurait même fait
une crise de nerf quand on a voulu la
fouiller on a l'impression d'un
comportement de diva c'est ça qui choque
un peu tranquille dans sa cellule en
regardant la télé même si on a le droit
d'avoir la télé mais ça choque quand
même est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
la télé c'est elle a été introduit en
détention en 1985 oui ça fait 37 ans
qu'elle a la télé en détention
je peux comprendre que ça peut choquer
moi je pense que ça me choque moi
il y a plein d'autres choses qui peut
choquer et c'est vrai il y a des choses
qui me choque aujourd'hui de faire venir
des motos pour faire des freestyle en
détention ça me choque
dans un état de santé ça me choque plus
qu'une télé moi je suis pas d'accord
avec toi je te dis moi je veux bien
qu'on en parle pas de souci
une télé pour quelqu'un qui a commis un
meurtre aussi monstrueux je suis désolé
pour moi c'est pas et à la télé c'est un
loisir pour quelqu'un comme d'hab bien
qui a fait quelque chose de monstru
c'est censé être un lieu de punitions
dans une chambre avec la télé
dans ce qu'elle chante qu'elle manque de
respect aux personnes finances et par
dessus le marché la droite se divertir
en regardant la télé mais pardon moi
Damien j'ai pas envie qu'elle regarde
les Marseillais qu'elle s'amuse
comment comment
s'informer pour se divertir c'est quoi
tout le monde c'est vrai qu'il est pas
responsable pour hein bien sûr on n'est
pas là pour faire justice on est là pour
appliquer qui décide de ça c'est le
directeur aussi le garde des sceaux
les seules personnes qui n'ont pas le
droit de télé ça s'enlève moi je suis
désolé
c'est ceux qui sont placés au quartier
discipliné
pourquoi
on peut laver la télé qu'on ne comprend
pas on ne comprend pas c'est pourquoi
une personne comme ça n'est pas entre
guillemets soumise au régime du quartier
d'ici bien sûr c'est ça
qui commettent des fautes en
détentionner et forcément il y a une
sanction on sait que vous faites travail
mais ça prouve bien que c'est mal fait
je suis désolé mais je sais c'est pas de
voter le débat il est intéressant parce
que souvent ici on critique quand moi je
suis avec l'épreuve quand on a des
preuves des tests ADN quand on sait que
c'est vraiment la coupable je suis moi
je rigole même pas je me pose toujours
la question pourquoi la nourriture 40
donc voilà le rire des années en prison
voilà j'arrête là-dessus moi c'est pas
le débat de la télé qui moi la télé
voilà je m'en fous moi je me demande
pourquoi la nourrir des années après un
autre débat
des animaux alors vous laissez le mari
voulait en rajoutez quelque chose
à rajouter ce qui a été dit on on parle
de l'incident là du 1er novembre à
l'occasion d'un changement de cellule
elle a soupirait parce qu'elle a subi
une fouille à Corse
elle voulait pas se faire fouiller euh
bon euh alors elle a soupirait elle a
dit mais on peut vraiment se poser la
question on avait évoqué d'ailleurs
cette cet aspect des choses sur ce
plateau il y a quelques jours de la
santé mentale de cette fille
vous allez me l'énerver Mathieu non ce
que je veux dire très court mais être
déjà dans 9 m² toute sa vie c'est déjà
une punition énorme
de détention qui chassent les animaux
en faire des animaux
excuse-moi quand les conditions énormes
dans 9 mètres carrés la jeune femme
qu'on a reçu l'autre jour elle vivait
dans 9 mètres carrés et Lola ne
regardera plus jamais la télé alors tu
ne seras pas
d'accord avec Daniel là ce que tu dis
c'est n'importe quoi